les avions et les navires militaires
russes se déploie en direction de la mer
noire en organisant ces exercices de
grande ampleur moscou concrétise ces
annonces face aux activités de l'otan
qu'ils jugent menaçante une réaction
jugée proportionnée par le ministre
russe de la défense
en réaction aux activités militaires
menaçante de l'alliance atlantique nous
avons pris les mesures appropriées en
trois semaines les armes et trois
divisions de troupes aéroportées ont pu
être transférés vers les frontières
occidentale de la russie pour participer
à ces manoeuvres russe coïncide avec la
visite du secrétaire à la défense
américain à bruxelles à l'occasion d'une
consultation menée par l'otan alors que
l'ukraine et la russie s'accusant
mutuellement de masser des soldats leurs
frontières respectives
washington annonce l'envoi de 500
militaires supplémentaires en allemagne
une décision qui satisfait le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne
ce dernier a sollicité l'aide du
secrétaire général de l'otan jens
stoltenberg
l'ukraine et nos amis restent vigilants
nous ne perdons pas et nous ne perdrons
pas de temps et si moscou devait prendre
des mesure imprudente ou entamer
nouvelle spirale de violence cela
coûterait cher dans tous les sens du
terme
je tiens à vous rassurer l'ukraine ne
veut pas la guerre nous ne prévoyons pas
d'offensive ou d' escalade
le crem se repose sur les moyens
diplomatiques et politiques pour régler
ce conflit
les tensions entre occidentaux et russes
sont directement liés à la reprise des
combats ces dernières semaines dans le
dombass région de l'est de l'ukraine où
l'armée gouvernementale combat des
séparatistes depuis 2014 alors que des
pourparlers doivent reprendre
prochainement kiev paris berlin et
moscou
le processus politique est toujours figé
c'est dans ce contexte que joe biden et
vladimir poutine se sont entretenus au
téléphone le président américain a
proposé à son homologue russe
d'organiser une rencontre dans les
prochains mois
afin de bâtir une relation stable avec
la russie selon les mots de la maison
blanche
la prenne au kremlin les deux dirigeants
se sont dits prêts à poursuivre le
dialogue pour garantir la sécurité
mondiale